[Applause]  I don't know if he's here but I really  want to thank Pharrell Williams because  again growing up feeling left-of-centre  to a lot of stuff that I saw on TV that  man has allowed me to be comfortable  with myself and has opened up doors that  you guys could not imagine before I met  him in when I met him so thank you  people I love y'all Tyler what is what  does this mean to win Wow you shiny I'm  very excited they cut they gave me to  wrap it up music that was tight I'm so  happy I got that where's your mom I  don't know I do not know where she is  I'm kind of I'm happy she came on but I  always keep my family super secret so  when she came on I was like no but like  it was all love everything was great I'm  hyped I'll probably go and do what I  normally would do on a Sunday night no  you're not you're Grammy winner now  you're gonna go crazy ha ha ha thanks so  much  [Music]